let me ask you about uh the war in
Ukraine why did Russia invade Ukraine on
February 24th
2022 what are some of the explanations
given and which do you find the most
convincing well clearly the conventional
wisdom is that Putin uh is principally
responsible Putin is an imperialist uh
he's an expansionist that's the
conventional thinking yeah yeah and the
idea is that uh he he uh is bent on
creating a greater Russia uh and even
more so he's interested in dominating
Eastern Europe if not all of Europe um
and that Ukraine was the first stop on
the train line uh and what he wanted to
do was to conquer all of Ukraine uh
incorporated into a greater Russia and
then he would move on and conquer other
countries this is the conventional
wisdom my view is there is no evidence
uh let me emphasize zero evidence to
support that argument which part that he
would the imperialist part the sense
that he would he sought to conquer all
of Ukraine and move on and Conquer
there's no evidence he was interested in
conquering all of Ukraine there was no
interested there's no evidence
beforehand that he was interested in
coning conquering any of Ukraine and
there's no way that an army that
had 90,000 troops at the
most right could have conquered all of
Ukraine just impossible as I like to
emphasize when the Germans went into
Poland in
1939 uh and the Germans you want to
remember were only intent on Conquering
the Western half of Poland because the
Soviets uh who came in later that month
we're going to conquer the eastern half
of Poland so the Western half of Poland
is much smaller than Ukraine and the
Germans went in with 1.5 million troops
uh If U Vladimir Putin were bent on
conquering all of Ukraine he would have
needed at least two million troops I
would argue he' need three million
troops because not only do you need to
conquer the country you then have to
occupy it uh but the idea that 190,000
troops was sufficient for conquering uh
all of Ukraine is not a serious argument
furthermore he was not interested in
conquering Ukraine and that's why in
March 2022 this is immediately after the
war starts he is negotiating with
zalinski to end the war there are
serious
negotiations taking place in Istanbul
involving the Turks and Naf Tali Bennett
Who was the Israeli Prime Minister at
the time was deeply involved in
negotiating with both Putin and zalinski
to end the war well if he was interested
Putin in conquering all of Ukraine why
in God's name would he be negotiating
with zalinski to end the war and of
course what they were negotiating about
was NATO expansion into Ukraine which
was the principal cause of the war uh
people in the west don't want to hear
that AR argument because if it is true
which it is then the West is principally
responsible for this bloodbath that's
now taking place and of course the West
doesn't want to be principally
responsible it wants to blame Vladimir
Putin so we've invented this story out
of whole cloth that he is an aggressor
that he's the second coming of Adolf
Hitler and that what he did in Ukraine
was try to uh to conquer all of it and
he failed but uh with a little bit of
luck he probably would have conquered
all of it and he'd now be in the Baltic
states and eventually end up uh
dominating all of Eastern Europe as I
said I think there's no evidence to
support this so maybe there's a lot of
things to ask there maybe just to linger
on NATO
expansion what is NATO
expansion what is the threat of NATO
expansion and why is it such a concern
for
Russia NATO
was a mortal enemy of the Soviet Union
during the Cold War it's a military
Alliance which has at its heart the
United States of America which is the
most powerful State on the planet it is
perfectly understandable that Russia is
not going to want that military Alliance
on its doorstep here in the United
States we have as you well know what's
called the Monroe Doctrine and that
basically says say no great powers from
Europe or Asia are allowed to come into
our neighborhood and form a military
alliance with anybody in this
neighborhood uh when I was young there
was this thing called the Cuban Missile
Crisis the Soviets had the audacity to
put nuclear armed missiles in Cuba we
told them in no uncertain terms that
that was not acceptable and that those
missiles had to be removed this is our
backyard and we do not tolerate distant
great powers coming into our
neighborhood well what's good for the
goose is good for the gander and if we
don't like great Powers coming into our
neighborhood it's hardly surprising that
the Russians did not want NATO on their
doorstep uh they made that manifestly
clear um when the Cold War ended and
they exacted a promise from us that we
would not expand NATO and then when we
started expanding NATO
they made it clear after the first
trunch in 1999 that they were profoundly
unhappy with that they made it clear in
2004 after the second trunch that they
were profoundly unhappy with that
expansion and then in April 2008 when
NATO announced that uh Ukraine and
Georgia would become part of NATO they
made it unequivocally clear not just
Putin that that was not going to happen
happened they were drawing a Red Line in
the Sand and it is no accident that in
August 2008 remember the Bucharest
Summit is April 2008 and August 2008 you
had a war between Georgia and Russia and
that involved at its core NATO expansion
so uh the Americans and their allies
should have understood by at least
August 2008 that continuing to push to
bring Ukraine into NATO was going to
lead to disaster and I would note that
there were all sorts of people in the
1990s like George Kennan William Perry
who was Bill Clinton's Secretary of
Defense the chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff Paul Nitza and so forth and so
on who argued that NATO expansion would
end up producing a disaster which it has
I would note that uh at the famous April
2008 Bucharest Summit where NATO said
that Ukraine would be brought into the
alliance Angela Merkel and uh Nicholas
sarosi the German and French leaders
respectively opposed that decision
Angela Merkel later said that the reason
she opposed it was because she
understood that Putin would interpret it
as a declaration of war just think about
that Merkel is telling you that she
opposed osed NATO expansion into Ukraine
because she understood correctly that
Putin would see it as a declaration of
war what did the United States and its
friend in friends in Europe do they
continued to push and push because we
thought that we could push NATO
expansion down their throat after 2008
the same way we did in 1999 and 2004 but
we were wrong and it all blew up in our
face in
2014 and when it blew up in our face in
2014 what did we do did we back off and
say well maybe the Russians have some
legitimate security interest no that's
not the way we operate we continue to
double down and the end result is that
in 2022 you got a war and as I've argued
for a long time now we the West are
principally responsible for that not
Vladimir Putin so the expansion of NATO
was primarily responsible yeah to put it
in more general terms what we were
trying to do was turn Ukraine into a
Western bwar on Russia's border and it
really wasn't NATO expansion alone NATO
expansion was the most important element
of our strategy but the strategy had two
other dimensions one was EU expansion
and the third was the color
Revolution we were trying to fost Orange
Revolution ution in Ukraine and the
basic goal there was to turn Ukraine
into a pro-western liberal
democracy and that meant that you'd have
Ukraine if it worked as a pro-western
liberal democracy that was in the EU and
that was in NATO this was our goal and
the Russians made it unequivocally clear
Ukraine was not going to become a
Western bullwark on their border and
most importantly they made it clear that
Ukraine in NATO was
unacceptable can we talk about the mind
of Vladimir Putin you've mentioned that
this idea that he has aspirations
for uh imperialist
Conquest that he dreams of Empire is not
grounded in reality he wrote an essay in
2021 about one
people do you think there is some degree
to which he still dreams of the former
Soviet Union
reuniting no he's made it clear that uh
anybody with a a triple digit IQ
understands that it's nuts to think
about recreating the Soviet
Union he thinks it's a tragedy that the
Soviet Union fell apart but as he made
clear in that essay the July 12th 2021
essay and has he made clear in speeches
before immediately before he invaded
Ukraine he
accepted uh the breakup of the Soviet
Union and he accepted uh the status quo
in in Europe save for the fact he did
not accept the idea that Ukraine would
become part of NATO he's been in power
for over two decades is there a degree
that power can
affect a Leader's ability to see the
world clearly as they say
corrupt um do you think power has
corrupted Vladimir Putin to a degree
it's very hard for me to answer that
question because I don't know him and
I've not studied him carefully uh in
terms of his overall performance over
the course of you know the 23 years that
he's been in
power um I've studied him as a
strategist and I've studied how he you
know deals with the West uh and you know
deals with the International System more
generally uh since
2014 and I think he is a first class
strategist this is not to say he doesn't
make
mistakes uh and he admits he's made some
mistakes uh U but uh I think that the
West is dealing with a formidable
adversary here uh and I don't see any
evidence that he's either lost speed off
his fast ball or that power has
corrupted his thinking about strategic
Affairs so he has consistently put as a
primary concern
security as does the United States he's
put for Russia security making sure that
NATO doesn't get close to its borders I
think that's clear yeah I I think as I
emphasized early on in our conversation
that leaders privilege security or
survival over everything else and by the
way he gave a number of talks uh and
press
conferences uh in addition to writing
that famous article that you referred to
on July 12 2021 so we have you know a
pretty clear record of what he was
saying and I would argue what he was
thinking in the runup to the war in
February
2022 and if you read uh what he said uh
it's quite clear that he privileged
security or survival he was deeply
concerned about the security of Russia
and Russia is a quite vulnerable state
in a lot of ways especially if you think
back to what it looked like in the 1990s
is you know better than I do uh it was
in terrible shape uh the Chinese talk
about the century of national
humiliation one could argue that for the
Russians that was the decade of national
humiliation and um and it took Putin I
think quite a bit of time to bring the
Russians back from the dead I think he
eventually succeeded but uh it took a
considerable amount of time and I think
he understood that he was not playing a
particularly strong hand he was playing
something of a weak hand and he had to
be very careful very cautious and I
think he was uh and I think that's very
different than the United States the
United States was the unipole it was the
most powerful state in the history of
the world most powerful State relative
to all its possible competitors from you
know roughly 1989 certainly after
December 1991 when the Soviet Union fell
apart up until I would argue about 2017
we were incredibly powerful even after
2017 up to today the United States
Remains the most powerful state in the
system and because of our geographical
location uh we are in a uh
terrific uh situation to survive in any
great power competition so uh you have a
situation involving the United States
that's different than the situation
involving Russia they're they're just
much more vulnerable uh than we are and
and therefore I think Putin tends to be
more sensitive about
security than any American president in
recent Times Europe on one side China on
the other side it's a complicated
situation yeah and we talked before
about 182 when Napoleon invaded and
Moscow got burned to the ground we
talked about World War I where the
Russians were actually defeated uh and
surrendered uh and then we talked about
1941 went to 1945 where although
thankfully uh the Soviets prevailed uh
it was uh it was a close call and I mean
the casualties the destruction that the
Soviet
Union uh had inflicted on it by the
Germans is just almost almost hard to
believe it
just uh so they are sensitive you can
understand full well or at least you
should be able to understand full well
why the idea of bringing Ukraine up to
their border really spooked them uh I
don't understand why more Americans
don't understand that it just it it
befuddles me I think it has to do with
the fact that Americans are not very
good in putting themselves in the shoes
of other countries uh and uh you really
if if you're going to be a first class
strategist in international politics you
have to be able to do that you have to
put yourself in the shoes of the other
side and think about how they think so
you don't make foolish mistakes and as a
starting point Americans tend to see
themselves as the good guys and a set of
others as the bad guys and you have to
be able to empathize that Russians think
of themselves as the good guys the
Chinese think of themselves as the good
guys and just be able to empathize if
they are the good guys it's like that uh
funny skit are we the baddies cons the
United States could be the bad guys like
first of all like see the world if the
United States is the bad guys and China
is the good guys what does that world
look like be able to just exist with
that thought because that is what the
Chinese leadership and many Chinese
citizens uh if not now maybe in the
future will believe and you have to kind
of do the calculation the simulation
forward from that and same with Russia
same with with other nations yeah I
agree with you 100% and just you know I
always think of Michael McFall at
Stanford who was the American ambassador
to uh Russia I think between 2012 and
2014 and uh he told me that he told
Putin uh that Putin didn't have to worry
about NATO expansion because the United
States was a benign
hegemon and uh I asked Mike what Putin's
response was to that that and uh Mike
said that Putin didn't believe it uh and
uh but Mike believed it he should
believe it and that we could move NATO
Eastward to include Ukraine and in the
end we'd get away with it because we are
a benign haimon but the fact is that's
not what Putin saw Putin saw us as a
malign hegemon and what Mike thinks or
any American thinks doesn't matter what
matters is what Putin thinks but also
the drums of War have been beating for
some reason NATO expansion has been
threatened for some reason so you've
talked about NATO expansion being
dead so like it doesn't make sense from
a geop political perspective on the
Europe side to expand NATO uh but
nevertheless that threat has been uh
echoed so um why has NATO expansion been
pushed from your perspective there are
two reasons one is first of all we
thought it was a wonderful thing uh to
bring more and more countries into NATO
we thought that it facilitated peace and
prosperity it was ultimately all for the
good um and uh we also thought that uh
uh countries like Ukraine had a right to
join NATO these are sovereign countries
that can decide for themselves and the
Russians have no say in what Ukraine
wants to do and then finally and this is
a point I emphasized before we were very
powerful and we thought we could shove
it down their throat so so it's a
combination of those factors that led us
to pursue what I think was ultimately uh
a foolish
policy we've talked about how Wars get
started
how do you hope the war in Ukraine ends
what are the ways to end this war what
are the ways to achieve peace there to
uh end the
the I would say
senseless death of young men as always
happens in
War I I'm sad to say I don't have a good
answer to that um I I don't think
there's any real process ECT of a
meaningful peace agreement I think it's
almost
impossible uh I I think the best you can
hope for uh at this point is it's some
some point the shooting stops you have
ceasefire and then you have a frozen
conflict uh and that Frozen conflict uh
will not be highly stable uh and uh the
uh ukrainians and the West will do
everything they can to weaken Russia's
position uh and the Russians will go to
Great Lengths to not only damage that
dysfunctional rum state that Ukraine
becomes but the Russians will go to
Great Lengths to seow dissension within
the alliance and uh and that includes in
terms of transatlantic relations so
you'll have this
continuing security competition between
Russia on one side and Ukraine and the
West on the other even when you get a fr
Frozen
peace uh and um or you get a frozen
conflict and uh and and and the
potential for escalation there will be
great uh so I think this is a disaster
that's a very realist perspective let me
ask you sort of a the The Human Side of
it do you think there's some power to
leader sitting down having a
conversation man to man leader to leader
about this there's there there is just a
lot of death
happening it seems that from a economic
perspective from a historic perspec from
a human perspective both nations are
losing is it possible for Vladimir
zalinski and and and Vladimir Putin to
sit down and talk and
to uh figure out a way where uh the
security concerns are addressed and both
Nations can can um minimize the amount
of suffering that's happening and and
and create a a path towards future
flourishing I think the answer is no
even with uh United States involved
three people in the room well I think
you if the United States is involved the
answer is definitely no you have to get
the Americans out uh and then I I think
if you have zinski and Putin talking you
know you have a sliver of chance there
the Americans
are a real problem look let's go back to
what happens right after the war starts
okay as I said before this is we're
talking March early April of 2022 the
war starts on February 24th
2022 and as I said to you uh the two
sides were negotiating in aan buul and
they were also uh negotiating through
Neftali Bennett and the Bennett track
and the Turkish track were operating
together I mean they were not at Cross
purposes at
all what
happened Bennett tells the story very
clearly that they had made significant
progress in reaching an agreement this
is zalinski on one side and Putin on the
other Bennett is talking in person to
both Putin and uh
zalinski and
what happens to produce failure the
answer is the United States and Britain
get involved and tell zinsky to walk
they tell zinsky to walk if they had
come in and encouraged zinski to try to
figure out a way with Putin to shut this
one down and worked with Bennett and
worked with
erdogan we might have been able to shut
the war down then but it was the United
States well let me sort of uh push back
on that you you're you're you're correct
but so United States paints this like um
picture that everybody's aligned so I
maybe you can correct me but I believe
in the power of individuals especially
individual leaders again whether it's
Biden or Trump or whoever goes into a
room and says in a way that's convincing
that no more NATO
expansion and actually just on a basic
human
level ask the question of why are we
doing all this senseless
killing and look at the interest of one
Russia look at the interest of the other
Ukraine their interests are pretty
simple and say United States is going to
stay out of this we're not going to
expand NATO and say all that in a way
that's convincing which is NATO
expansion is silly at this point china
is the big threat we're not going to do
this kind of of conflict escalation with
Russia the Cold War is Over let's let's
uh normalize relations well let me just
embellish your argument okay thank
you I need it if we say there's a sliver
of a chance that you can do this and I
do think there is a sliver of a chance
let me just embellish your point Thank
you need all the help I can get two
things have to be done here in my
opinion one is uh
Ukraine has to become
neutral and it has to completely sever
all security ties with the West
right it's not like uh you can say we're
not going to expand NATO to include
Ukraine but we're going to continue to
have some loose security arrangement
with Ukraine none of that has to be
completely severed Ukraine has to be on
its own Zone okay and number two Ukraine
has to accept the fact that the Russians
are going to keep the four oblas that
they've now annexed and
Crimea right the Russians are not going
to give them back and what you really
want to do if you're zalinski or who's
ever running Ukraine in this scenario
that we're positing is you want to make
sure the Russians don't take another
four oblas to include ke and Odessa
right if I'm playing Putin's hand and
this war goes on I'm thinking about
taking four more oblas I I want to take
about 43% of Ukraine and Annex it to
Russia right and I certainly want Odessa
uh and I certainly want harke and I I
want the two o Bloss in between as well
right literally or as uh leverage in
negotiation no I neutrality I want them
literally uh I want to conquer them
literally uh but my point to you is if
we can begin to talk about cutting a
deal now you may be able to head that
kind of aggression off at the past in
other words you may be able to limit
Putin and Russia to annexing the four
oblas that they've now annexed plus
Crimea that's the best I think you can
hope for but the point is you have to
get the ukrainians to accept that you
have to get the ukrainians to accept
becoming a truly neutral State and
conceding that the Russians keep a big
chunk of territory it's about 23% of
Ukrainian territory that they've
annexed and I find it hard to imagine
any Ukrainian leader agreeing to that
well there there there could be more
Nuance things like no military
involvement between the United States
and Ukraine but economic involvement
sort of uh financial
support So of normalizing economic
relationships with Ukraine with Russia I
think I think you could probably get
away with that I I think the the the
tricky question there that you would
have to answer is what about EU
expansion right and I think EU expansion
is probably a no no for the Russians
because most people don't recognize this
but there is a military Dimension built
in to EU expansion it's not not purely
an
economic uh Alliance uh or relationship
or institution whatever word you want to
use there's a military Dimension to that
and in the runup to the War uh actually
in the run up to the 2014 crisis when it
first broke out uh the Russians made it
clear they saw EU expansion as a
stalking horse for NATO expansion so EU
expans ion is tricky but I I think your
point of close economic relations
between or healthy economic relations to
use a better term between Ukraine and
the West is possible I I I think the
Russians have a vested interest in if if
it's a neutral Ukraine they have a
vested interest in that Ukraine
flourishing but then then brings us back
to the territorial issue all right well
so do you believe it's possible for
individual human relations to counteract
the structural forces that you talk
about so meaning the
leaders being able to pick up the phone
and make agreements that are good for
Humanity as a whole and for their
individual nations in the long term I
think leadership matters here
uh I mean one of the real problems here
is that there's no trust and on the
Russian side and that has to do do with
the Minsk agreements um the uh uh the
Minsk agreements uh which were designed
to shut down the Civil
War uh in eastern Ukraine in the donbass
um really mattered to the Russians and
there were four players involved in the
uh uh the min's process uh four main
players Russia and Ukraine of course and
then Germany and
France and and uh I believe the Russians
took the Minsk Accords seriously uh I
believe Putin took them very seriously
he wanted a shut down that
conflict um and uh Angela Merkel
Francois Holland he was the French
leader and penko who was the Ukrainian
leader those were the three key players
besides Putin again Holan from France
Merkel from Germany and penko from
Ukraine have all explicitly said they
were not seriously interested in
reaching an agreement in all of the
discussions with Putin they were
bamboozling him they were trying to
trick him so that they would buy time to
build up Ukraine's military uh Putin is
profoundly upset about these admissions
by these three leaders he believes he
was fooled into thinking that Mintz
could work he believes that he
negotiated in good faith and they did
not and he believes that the level of
trust now between Russia uh and the West
is virtually zero as a result of this
experience over Minsk I only bring this
up because it cuts against your argument
that leaders could pick up the phone and
talk to each other and trust each other
at least somewhat uh to work out a
meaningful deal if you're Putin at this
point in time trusting the West is not
an idea that's going to be very
attractive at all in fact you're going
to distrust anything they say yeah
distrust anything the West say but there
is individual humans the way human
nature works is when you sit in AC cross
from a person you can trust a human
being while still d trusting the West I
mean I I I believe in the power of that
I I think with the right leaders you can
sit down and talk like over override the
general structural distrust of the West
and say you know what I like this guy or
gal whatever I do hope zalinski and
Putin sit down together and talk have
multiple
talks just remember they were doing that
in March and the Americans came in and
the British came in yeah and they
scotched a potential
deal
well uh the other beautiful thing about
human nature there's forgiveness and
there's uh trying again when you're the
leader of a country in an anarchic
system you have to be very careful not
to let uh your trust in a foreign leader
take you too far because if that foreign
leader betrays you or betrays your trust
and stabs you in the back you could die
and again you want to remember that the
principal responsibility of any leader I
don't care what country it is is to
ensure the survival of their state and
that means that you know trust is only
going to buy you so much and when you've
already
betrayed the trust of a leader uh you
really are not going to be able to rely
on trust very much to help you moving
forward now you disagree with that I
hope you're right and if they can shut
down the Ukraine Russia War uh it would
be wonderful if if I'm proved dead wrong
uh that would be wonderful news uh
my my prediction that this war is going
to go on for a long time and
uh and end in an ugly way is a
prediction that
I don't like it all so I hope I'm wrong
you wrote that many in the west believe
that the best hope for ending the
Ukraine Wars to remove Vladimir Putin
from power but you argue that uh this
isn't the
case can you explain well a lot of
people thought when uh they were having
all that trouble the Russians were
having all that trouble with progan and
the Vagner group that Putin was
vulnerable and was likely to be
overthrown and what would happen is uh a
peaceloving leader would replace Putin
uh I made two points at the time and I
would make those same two points now
number one he's not
likely to be overthrown he was not
likely then to be
overthrown uh and I think you know as
long as his Health holds up I think he
will remain in power my second point is
if he doesn't remain in power and he's
replaced I would bet a lot of money that
his replacement will be more hawkish and
more Hardline than Putin is uh I
actually think one could argue that
Putin was too trusting of the West
before the war
started uh and number two I think one
could argue that he has not waged the
war against Ukraine as vigorously as one
might have
expected uh he was slow to mobilize the
nation for War uh and he has pursued a
limited war in all sorts of ways uh the
Israelis for example have killed more
civilians in Gaza in one month than the
Russians have killed over 18 months in
Ukraine the idea that Vladimir Putin is
waging a punishment campaign and killing
on purpose large numbers of civilians is
simply not true uh all this is to say
that uh I would imagine that if Putin
leaves office and someone else comes in
to replace him that someone else will be
at least if not more Hardline than him
in terms of waging the war and certainly
will not trust the West anym than he
has by way of advice let me ask you if I
were to have a conversation interview
Vladimir Putin and zalinski
individually what should I ask them if
you me and Vladimir Putin are having a
chat what are
good ideas to explore what are good
questions to ask what are good things to
say onor off the mic once again that
could
potentially even slightly lessen the
amount of suffering in the world caused
by this war oh I think if you get an
interview with Vladimir Putin there's
just all sorts of questions you could
ask him and my sense is that Putin is a
straight shooter uh he's also very
knowledgeable about history and he has
simple theories in his head about how
the world works and I think he would
level with you and all you would have to
do is just you know figure out what all
the right questions are and that would
not be hard to do right uh you know you
could ask him why was he so foolish this
is for for example why was he so foolish
is to uh uh trust uh poreno Holland and
Merkel uh in the Minsk
Accords uh you know why after his famous
talk at unic in 2007 where he made it
clear that he was so unhappy with the
West uh did he continue uh to you know
in a very important way trust the West
why didn't he mobilize uh the Russian
military before late September
2022 uh you know once the negotiations
that we were talking about before uh
involving this St ball uh and uh Na Tali
Ben and once they broke down you know
why didn't he immediately mobilize more
of the Russian population to fight the
war just all sorts of questions like
that and then you could ask them
questions about you know where uh he
sees this one headed uh what's the best
strategy for Russia uh if the ukrainians
will not agree to neutrality right you
know people like John mimer say you'll
probably take uh close to half of
Ukraine is that true does it make sense
to take
Odessa and John mimer also has questions
about
China your future relationships with
China yeah I mean one really important
question that I would ask them is if the
United States had basically not driven
you into the arms of the Chinese if
there had been no war over Ukraine and
the United States had and its European
allies had gone to considerable length
to create some sort of security
architecture in Europe uh that resulted
in you Vladimir Putin having good
relations with Ukraine what would your
relations with China be uh and uh you
know how would you think about that uh
so there there are just plenty of
questions you could ask
him well hope Burns Eternal in my heart
I think probably in Putin's heart and
zelinsky's heart I
hope cuz hope is uh the leap of trust
that we've talked about I think is
necessary for deescalation and for peace
well you realize I have from the
beginning argued for different policies
that were all designed to prevent this
war from ever happening yes I don't know
if you know this but in 1993 I argued
that Ukraine should keep its nuclear
weapons I was probably the only person
in the west who made that argument and
my argument in 1993 this is in foreign
affairs was that there may come the day
when Russia thinks about invading
Ukraine and should that day come it
would be very helpful for preventing War
if Ukraine had nuclear weapons so
military might is essential for
maintaining a balance of power and peace
well if you're interested in deterring
an adversary if I'm worried about you
coming after me the best way to deter
you is to have military might and if
you're Russia and I'm Ukraine I'm far
weaker than you yeah right and having a
nuclear deterrent would be very
effective at convincing you not to
attack me because if you attack me
you're threatening my survival and
that's the one circumstance where it is
likely that I would use nuclear weapons
to defend myself and given the
consequences of nuclear use you would be
reluctant in the ex dream to attack me
so that's why I argued in 933 that if
Ukraine kept its nuclear weapons that
made War down the road much less likely
and I believe I was correct and in fact
Bill Clinton who played the key role in
forcing Ukraine to give up its nuclear
weapons now says he has said it publicly
you can find it on YouTube that he made
a mistake doing that furthermore I
argued in
2014 that it made eminently good sense
not to continue to push to bring Ukraine
into NATO because the end result is that
Ukraine would be destroyed and Ukraine
is being destroyed so I was deeply
interested at the time in making sure
that that didn't happen for the good of
the ukrainians not to mention because
stability in Europe is a net positive
for almost everybody involved but people
did not listen to me then either how do
nuclear weapons change the calculus of
offensive realism because of mutually
ass destruction I mean it's not just
military might it's just so
destructive that you basically can't use
nuclear
weapons unless you want complete
destruction there's no question that the
presence of nuclear weapons makes it
much less likely I'm choosing my words
carefully here much less likely that a
great power would aggress against
another great power it doesn't take that
possibility off the table but it makes
it much less likely because of the
reasons that you
articulated uh but with regard to
nuclear
use it's an interesting question how you
think about nuclear use in a mad world I
mean your point that we're in a mad
world
is that's mad Capital mad as well as mad
small letters but let's stick to the
capital letters we're in a world of
Mutual Assurance
destruction U there's no question that
in that
World um it's uh unlikely that nuclear
weapons would be used but the way you
use nuclear weapons in that world is you
use them uh for manipulation or risk
purposes demonstration of fact you you
put both sides out on the slippery slope
now what exactly am I saying here let me
talk about NATO Doctrine during the Cold
War we lived in a Mad World United
States and Soviet Union or the warsa PCT
in NATO both had an assured destruction
capability so you had mutual assured
destruction if the warsa paact were to
invade Western Europe and here we're
talking about West
Germany uh and NATO was losing the war
we said that we would use nuclear
weapons how would we use nuclear weapons
given that we were in a Mad World the
argument was that we would use a handful
of nuclear weapons Against The warsa
Pact not through not necessarily against
their military forces could be in a
remote area we would use a small number
of nuclear weapons MH to signal to the
Soviets that we were deadly serious
about putting an end to their
offensive uh and and that we were
throwing both sides out on the slippery
slope to Oblivion in other words we were
manipulating risk and the last clear
chance to avoid Armageddon rested with
them MH and then we would tell them that
if you retaliated with a handful of
nuclear weapons and you didn't cease
your offensive against West Germany we
would launch a small another nuclear
attack we would U explode a handful more
of nuclear weapons all for the purposes
of showing you our resolve right so this
is the manipulation of risk strategy and
a lot of the language I just used in
describing it to you is language that
Thomas shelling invented right now fast
forward to the present if Russia were
you losing in Ukraine that's the one
scenario or I think where Russia would
have used nuclear weapons and the
question is how would Russia have used
nuclear weapons again we're assuming
that the Russians are losing to the
ukrainians I believe they would have
pursued a manipulation of risk strategy
they would have used four or five three
or four who knows nuclear weapons maybe
just one in a rural area that kills very
few people yes exactly and basically
that would spook everybody the Americans
just the mushroom cloud
yeah the it it's because of the threat
of escalation right again your point is
we're in a mad world I accept that and
if you have limited nuclear use right we
understand hardly anything about nuclear
escalation because thank goodness we've
never had a nuclear war so once you
throw both sides out on the slippery
slope even if you only use one nuclear
weapon in your scenario you don't know
what the escalation Dynamics look like
so everybody has a powerful incentive to
put an end to the conflict right away I
might add to you that there were people
who believed that we would not even
initiate a manipulation of risk strategy
in Europe if we were losing to the warsa
PCT during the Cold War both Henry
Kissinger and Robert mcnamar said after
leaving
office that they would not have done it
they would have not initiated nuclear
use even limited nuclear that's what
we're talking about here they would
rather be red than dead right that was
the argument too risky too risky that's
exactly right but if they had used one
nuclear weapon in your story or three or
four in my
story everybody would have said oh my
God we've got to shut this one down
immediately I only tell you this story
or lay out this scenario be as an answer
to your question of how you use nuclear
weapons in a mad world and this is the
answer I this is all very terrifying uh
perhaps in part it's terrifying to me
because I can see in the 21st
century China
Russia Israel United States using a
nuclear weapon in this way blowing it up
somewhere in the middle of nowhere that
kills maybe
nobody but I'm terrified of seeing the
mushroom cloud and not
knowing what you know given social media
given how fast news
travels what the escalation looks like
there just you know in in in a in a
matter of minutes how the news travels
and how the leaders react it's
terrifying that this this little
demonstration of power um the Ripple
effects of it in a matter of minutes
seconds what that leads to because it's
like it's human emotions it's like you
you see the landscape of human
emotions the leaders and the populace
and the and the way news are reported
and then the landscape of risk as you
mentioned shifting like the world's most
intense nonlinear dynamical
system and it it it it's just terrifying
because the the the entirety of human
civilizations hangs in the balance there
and it's like like
this like hundreds of millions of people
could be dead let's just talk about this
in the context of the Ukraine war
um if uh if the Russians were losing as
I said before which is not the case
anymore but in 2022 it it did look like
that um if the Russ are losing and they
turn to nuclear weapons the question is
how do they use them and they would use
them in
Ukraine and because Ukraine has no
nuclear weapons of its own Ukraine
cannot retaliate it's not a mutual
assured destruction world it's a case
where one side has nuclear weapons and
the other doesn't that means that the
Russians are likely to think that they
can get away with using nuclear weapons
in ways that would not be the case if
they were attacking NATO and therefore
it makes nuclear use more likely okay
that's point one point two is let's
assume that the Russians used two or
three nuclear weapons in a remote area
sweating by the way just just as a
commentary terrifying yeah the question
then is what does the West do now macron
has said and Biden has also Al I think
implicitly made this clear we would not
retaliate with nuclear weapons if the
Russians were to attack with a handful
of nuclear weapons in Western
Ukraine but then the question is what
would we Doh and if you listen to David
Petraeus what David Petraeus says is
that we should attack the Russian naval
Assets in the Black
Sea and attack Russian forces in
Ukraine well once you do that you have a
great power War you have NATO versus
Russia which is another way of saying
you have the United States versus Russia
we're now in a great power War they have
nuclear weapons we have nuclear weapons
they've used nuclear
weapons what is the happy ending here
and just to take it a step further and
go back to our earlier discussion about
moving NATO up to Russia's borders the
point I made which you surely agree with
is that the Russians are very fearful
when they see NATO coming up to their
border well here's a case where not only
is NATO come up to their border but
they're in a war with NATO right on
their
border what do the escalation Dynamics
look like there you know what the answer
is who knows that's should scare the
living but Jesus out of you right and
some of it could be like you mentioned
unintended
there could be unintended consequences
there could be a Russian missile misses
and hits
Poland these kinds of things that just
escalate misunderstandings
miscommunications even a I mean nuclear
weapon could be boy it could have been
planned to go location X and it went to
a location y that ended up actually
killing a very large number of people I
mean uh
just that the the escalation that
happens there just happens in in a
matter of minutes and the only way to
stop that is communication between
leaders and that to me is a big argument
for ongoing communication you know
there's a story that during the Cuban
Missile Crisis uh Kennedy put out the
word uh no
aircraft uh under any circumstances or
to penetrate Soviet airospace yeah yeah
and he then found out a few days later
that uh some guy hadn't gotten the
message and had penetrated in an
aircraft deep into Soviet airspace yeah
and uh this supports your basic point
that you know uh bad things happen and
uh and again the overarching point here
is we've never done this before
thankfully therefore we don't have a lot
of experience as to how it plays itself
out uh it it's really a theoretical
Enterprise because there's no empirical
basis for talking about
escalation uh you know in a nuclear
crisis and that of course is a wonderful
thing well in general the uh the human
species as a whole is a is a oneoff is a
theoretical Enterprise the survival of
the human species you know we've seen
Empires rise and fall but we haven't
seen the human species rise and fall so
far it's been rising but uh it's not OB
obvious that it doesn't end in fact I
think about aliens a lot and the fact
that we don't see aliens makes me
suspect it's not so easy to survive in
this complicated world of
ours